very miele nameless grave I came from
God the world who say I brought them
with them from above worship of liberty
and love they smoothly for I did
disparage therefore religion law and
marry so be my grave without an egg
butter may swallow up my shame
[Music]
hello people welcome to episode 24 of
the 13 o'clock podcast episodes are
stacking out we have waiting for
stacking out yeah and actually this one
we don't want to do this in for a while
this was requested on our kabini show
from a couple weeks ago Brandon yes
someone named Brandon on our YouTube
show asked if we would do a show about
Aleister Crowley Crowley eyes with holy
drives at home oh yeah yeah Holly why
not to be in everybody pretty much knows
who has to crow is but you know we can
do a brief over B I heard of the guy
actually when I was in high school uh
listen to audio
I was going to say that's probably when
like I don't know how to call it
yeah and back in those days it was hard
to find information it was pre-internet
so a lot of what you hear about them
would just be kind of like legend yeah
and I weren't sure if it was true or not
I think they're still not yeah and then
it was hard to find books about it yeah
yeah you go to the library you wouldn't
find ebooks on Crowley's
yeah I think particularly is like in
that time period like I said when when
you and me were the age growing up I
think a lot of people got into it
through you know Led Zeppelin and Ozzy
Osbourne and stuff like that girl yeah
cuz they were super into him yeah um but
you know obviously Marilyn Manson of his
time yeah it's gotta [ __ ] us yeah and I
mean like I said it's a huge huge topic
you can't cover no no and I didn't want
to just do like a biography because you
can look that up on Wikipedia or
whatever but um there's just be boring
yeah it would just be boring cuz never
done analyst can't do that yeah not
really so what we kind of ended up doing
was because his life was so crazy and
like he got into so much [ __ ] like over
his life and you're not sure how much of
it's true and you're not sure how much
of it is true because a lot of it was
you know confabulation and like later
media things that were attributed to him
and said curly was a teller of tall
tales
yeah it wouldn't really take Croley at
face value I don't believe yes some of
the stuff that he claims of
lawyer Mike Crowley defeated a female
vampire in his own words he said he did
that that's one of my very favorites
don't let the goal is on the guy for the
goal when you start making claims like
that yes that you gotta love the guy he
was a showman a showman storyteller and
a lot of stuff I think he really did do
like all the mountain climbing but we
can get all that yeah so basically what
we did was we kind of just picked out
kind of our favorite stories about him
whether they're true or not whether
they're true or not or our favorite like
conspiracy theories about it I thought
we'd kind of discuss some of those so
that's kind of all we're going to do so
like I said like like our usual show is
probably gonna be rambling and all over
the place I do have kind of an outline
but you know how that goes yeah I think
you know a baseline is as you look at
Crowley's life there are a lot of
parallels between Crowley
and so our h l ron hubbard yeah which
were yeah I'm going to get there in a
connection between the two and I think
that l ron hubbard emulated curly a lot
yeah I'm the tails that crow that
Aleister Crowley would tell it sounded
like he was kind of inspired by excuse
me well some of the tales that LRH or
Ellen Hubbard would tell sounds like
they were cruelly inspired yeah yeah no
he wanted to be kind of like Crowley I
think yeah and yeah that was definitely
one of the topics I want to get in okay
but really I was not in any particular
order but honestly I kind of wanted to
start you know obviously everybody knows
Aleister Crowley black magician born in
1875 and actually raised in a very very
strict Christian fundamentalist kind of
household his dad was a lay preacher in
the Plymouth Brethren and actually curly
was kind of into that when he was
younger like yeah you know but then when
he got into his teenage year and he
started to rebel as a lot of children of
fundamentalist backgrounds do now hold
on then this Christian Church that is
was his grandfather I believe this
started yeah Curly's grandfather started
when you really analyze that particular
Christian Church it was a cult
yeah it was a critical it was an
offshoot oh yeah it was bizarre
are they were biblical literal and raw
and you know they see a second coming
and all that kind of a big cult it was a
small Christian yeah yeah yeah but he
got you know he got raised in that and
but when he got into his teenage years I
way I told that wrong
it was Crowley's grandfather that made
all the money yes glad Abril Robert Dana
brewery is Crowley's father
that's that founded yes because there
was a wealthy family so Crowley's dad
was a cult leader give tomorrow and
Crowley when you really analyze his life
he was a cult leader also yeah well he
was actually a great admirer of his
father yeah but um but like I said when
probably got into his teenage years you
know he started to rebel and honestly it
almost seemed like he wanted to take on
the mantle of just the opposite of
everything because he was very he got
very into like the book of Revelation
and he kind of styled himself in that
sort of he kind of got to see a little
like the decadent poet's romanticism
where everything was like Luciferian
where he sympathized sympathy was for
the devil and all that guy can to help
you know and we had her puberty hit and
he started to go a while yeah pretty
much I mean boys and the girls yeah he
got kicked out of several yeah listen
thank you for various transgression
usually sexually and then he was started
to get into kind of like prototype BDSM
he wanted to be he had fantasized about
being the great any great advice
beautiful women wicked women wicked
women and he likes pain in some ways
kind of like Albert Fish but not so much
nuts but not really a real kill X was
religious and also kind of like state-o
masochistic that's kind of yeah he was
kind of into that and you know that was
his big bang banging hookers and yeah
you know things like that but um weirdly
I wanted to start with something a
little bit off the wall
we did a show about Victorian poisoners
before that were also Jack the Ripper
suspects now there's also kind of a
connection between Crowley and Jack the
Ripper yeah somewhat tenuous Crowley was
actually really interested in the Jack's
of
burb case now he claimed that one of his
earliest sexual conquests I guess was a
parlor maid this was when he was a
teenager where the parlor maid that
worked in the Crowley household yes and
he said you know when his family was
away he started like experimenting with
this girl and like he bummed her and his
mom's bed down with her mom and all this
other time you got yeah yeah and he said
that after this little dalliance was
found out about you know the family
fired at this particular parlor maid she
went out lived on the street as a
prostitute like she changed her name and
was later murdered by Jack the Ripper
yeah I don't believe a word I don't
think that's true but that said that
significally InStyle tale yeah somebody
would tell yeah it's a good story it is
a good story I did like that story but
oddly enough that wasn't the only Jack
the Ripper kind of connection like I
said Carly was super into Jack the
Ripper he actually wrote an essay called
Jack the Ripper in the 1930s I believe
and he said that he knew who Jack the
Ripper was and that it was a black
magician named Robert Johnson Stevenson
now he said he knew this because there
was this woman named Victoria Kremers
and she was a member of the Order Templi
Orientis you know which was you know the
magical society that Crowley was the
head of from 1912 to 1914 at least the
British branch of it and she said that
she thought that Robert Dunstan
Stevenson was the Ripper because she had
been talking to him about it one day and
I guess one of the big bones of
contention this time was well how could
he have walked around all covered in
blood and stuff like that and apparently
like he opened his overcoat was like hey
I could have what all over me and no one
would see it and stuff like that and
then she also said that she was in his
house she was looking for some love
letters from this other woman and she
looked like under the bed there was a
box under there and there were like all
these bloody dress tie
under there so she assumed that he was
Jack the river and she evidently told
this to Crowley now so Curley thought
that too it was now
Crowley thought that Jack the Ripper the
murders had been committed for some kind
of astrological or some kind of magical
purpose
now this isn't as nutty as it sounds
because even at the time the murders
were going on there were a few people
that kind of were into that theory that
it was some kind of magical right and
there was actually an anonymous letter
published in the Pall Mall Gazette in
1888 the same years and murders and this
person that wrote this letter said that
the murder site were like in the shape
of a cross and there were other things
going around that that the murders it
was done like a magic ritual like a life
asleep I like somebody trying to gain
magical power or somebody trying to make
like some kind of magical elixir from
eating the woman's body parts okay and
stuff like that so there was a lot of
that going around
now Crowley he thought maybe the the
murders were in the shape of a
five-pointed star which was another
thing going around some people also said
they were in the shape of that that's
fishy Jesus the Jesus fish II don't
think there's any evidence no I don't
think so either but like I said there
was some of that going around
and although Crowley actually thought
there were seven burgers not five which
was also kind of going around at the
time but Crowley did believe that the
the Ripper was a black magician and that
he was a cannibal and all this other
stuff right now it should be noted that
Robert Johnson Stevenson was never
considered a serious suspect by most
Ripper ologist mainly because he was
hospitalized the entire time that the
murders were taking place he was
hospitalized from like July of that year
to December of that year so he was
hospitalized
now some people still think that oh
maybe it was him and maybe the security
at the hospital blacks and he got out
almost other stuff and I was like anyone
really
that seriously now interestingly because
Crowley was so interested in Jack the
Ripper and because you know he was kind
of a weirdo yes later researchers let's
call them think that maybe Crowley might
have been a serial killer I don't think
anyone suggested that he was Jack the
Ripper which would be dumb but there
have been a few like kind of Fringe
conspiracies there aside people that
said that he was a copycat and that he
had killed apparently around the time
that the King Tut's tomb was discovered
in the 20s and there was like six deaths
in London that were attributed to King
Tut's curse and all really were
mysterious or whatever yeah and a couple
of conspiracy theorists have said that
Curley did those murders as kind of a
copycat and that and then he did it like
specifically so that would be attributed
to King Tut's curse but he did really
much but they must mean he did those
murders magically because looking about
yeah action yes that's what I think
there means yes various accidents oh
yeah
like I said this is a crazy story I just
thought that that was kind of a funny
like kind of funny juxtaposition there
but ya know I don't think anyone
seriously suggests no totally without it
you got a serial killer you got to give
collect context to Crowley's yeah and
you have to look at Curley in the
context of the times in the 1800s yeah
and even early 1900 he was these were
the goth kids of the 1800s
yeah that's their if he were to live
today I don't think he'd make a big
splash he wouldn't be noticed amongst
the other weirdos that we have today
yeah well not really because I mean at
the time like I said you know there was
kind of but because the Victorian era
scene is like very uptight and very
prudish and stuff like that they were
rebelling against this they were just
rebelling against that like I said the
Romantic poets decadent Pony kind of
exactly he had a lot in common with the
poets of the time yeah which were kind
of like experimenting with
unconventional sexuality and things of
that nature and in some ways he was kind
of like the beat writers yeah yeah we
rag about how decadent they were yeah
but yeah they were trying to like out
decadent each other right and actually
that kind of follows on to my next point
which is that curly he didn't I don't
think he really made a secret about his
bisexuality no um he mostly preferred
women hookers specifically but um what
was weird is that he was open he was
open about his bisector company who's
ashamed of his homosexuality yeah yeah
we're kind of strange thing yeah yeah
but um which that doesn't make sense if
you think about it but when you listen
to what their witnesses would say you
know he was embarrassed that he was a
bottom I think that's probably what they
had to justify well I need a magical
right this was just part of my duty for
this magical right yeah even though I
made this magical right up you know I
don't not really into this that's a
funny thing they come out magic it
wasn't magic as as you would think magic
would be I guess you could say seemed
like magic was mostly an excuse to have
sex and take drugs yeah but to say that
you had some kind of higher purpose
there was a higher purpose behind it and
let it just sit instead of just saying
that you liked it and you were into it
or right which you know nowadays people
would just be like I just like it I
don't care but right back then they kind
of needed some kind of an excuse yeah
like a grand kind of plan like I'm doing
this for a higher purpose yeah and you
make a magical order and then you keep
promoting yourself giving yourself
higher and higher title maybe we should
talk a little bit about that rolling
gone though I think one of the
interesting aspects of the Golden Dawn
if you join the Golden Dawn you had to
pay money and then you had to pay at
least test and paid money to go up into
higher higher level like I don't know
just like Scientology levels and I
believe that's where I believe that's
where l ron Hubbard got the idea yeah t
levels and I guess actually you kind of
skipped over my other thing but I guess
I gotta jump at all I guess we'll do the
Scientology thing since you're
enough now get okay good Telecom and
then I'll go back to the other thing but
yeah so we if you have been listening to
the show for a while a while back we did
a show on Scientology with special
guests the angry day post that was a
super fun show so if you haven't
listened to it you should go back and
let's do it but um so we've been like
endlessly fascinated by Scientology I
used to work for a company that's owned
by Scientologists in their nutcases and
I have run into Scientology yes books
yeah so so it's kind of something that's
interesting to us now there is a kind of
a connection between Crowley and
Scientology now l ron Hubbard claimed
that he met Aleister Crowley I don't
think he ever met him in person but you
know what they really think a lot of
this [ __ ] is hard to prove it's not
documented the writing legend right you
know this is just a scene imagine tried
to to get historical context of say like
the goth industrial scene it was getting
here say most of yeah most of its just a
method and Crawley's a lot like that
yeah I mean there's tons of stories
about him like I said you know Hubbard
says he met him other people say
probably not so much but what happened
was now l ron Hubbard and according to
his son and according to other people
that knew him l ron Hubbard was super
into the occult and he got into the
occult when he was 16 by reading
Crowley's book the book of the law and
so that was kind of that was kind of the
foundation of what would later become
Scientology according to his son
according to other people I don't get
out in one bit I don't either actually
because there are a lot of parallels now
Hubbard front like I said probably never
met Crowley in person but he did um they
claims - yeah he claimed - now he did
know a guy named Jack Parsons they
corresponded through letters now Jack
Parsons was a follower of the you know
magical ordered religion philosophy that
Crowley started called Salima and Jack
Parsons was also a member of the agape
Lodge in Pasadena which was of the
or to attempt Templi Orientis and so l
ron Hubbard a Jack Parsons evidently
inspired by a novel that Curley wrote in
1917 called moonchild they were trying
to do the sex magic ritual to bring
forth the Scarlet woman the fella might
goddess called Babylon and this series
of sex magic rituals was called Babylon
working okay and this took place over
several months
this was Hubbard and Parsons did this
evidently Parsons going to use a rocket
scientist wasn't yeah or some kind of
everything like that he was some kind of
scientist I guess living with the would
sell off with rocket fuel what no I
don't you guys like oh yeah that's
pretty fun but yeah so apparently they
liked this whole sex magic idea and they
they met this woman they met this woman
named what was her name I have it
written right here you know so many
figures involved with this vp's legends
they met yes Marjorie Cameron her name
is Marjorie Cameron and over the course
of Babylon working these sex magic
rituals they were trying to bring forth
a child you know not with each other
with Marjorie and never tried again
because that that would have been that
ended we had that was a pretty tense but
yeah so so yeah they were they were you
know doing stuff with this woman and
trying to trying to bring forth this
goddess this fella might goddess that
that curly had talked about by bringing
forth a child with his woman but
evidently it didn't work I mean she
never conceived a child or anything like
that alley inspiration for Rosemary's
Baby
yeah but that didn't stop Parsons from
saying that the rituals were successful
anyway okay the thing is because he
believed now he later married this
Marjorie Cameron he believed that she
was like an elemental spirit in human
form like you do like you do and you
know so so he said well we successfully
got her to come through you know so
that's so it's okay that number
got a kid but like I said Ronald the
wolf who is l ron hubbard son said that
hubbard based pretty much the entire
principles of Dianetics and Scientology
and stuff like that on black magic
specifically on Crowley's stuff okay and
he also said that when crowley died in
1947 whole ron hubbard supposedly wanted
to take on the mantle of the great beast
since that's what else are probably
called himself not about this yes and so
people say i don't know it's like people
kind of associate curly with Satanism he
wasn't really a statement no it's just
he was identifying with the beast of
Revelation yeah and although dark
Gnostic yeah I was kind of like that
magician but Hubbard apparently he said
well I'm gonna after you know after
Crowley died in nineteen forty sevens
ago I have to take on the mantle of the
Beast now and l ron hubbard son actually
said that hubbard thought that he was
Satan okay so I don't know how true that
is but that's what it sums up and so you
know Scientology that's a whole other
[ __ ] ball of wax will get into you
but like I said we didn't have an AGP
back on yeah we have to have an angry
gear boat back on but I mean I think
current Scientologists are trying to
like kind of not they don't really like
to talk about that no no no there's on
an Tama Bay connection yeah yeah yeah
but that's outside of scope oh yeah oh I
think the end but that if you know it's
a pretty common thing that I'm gonna
lose you know on Anton yeah we should
what yeah a little bit preschool - yeah
we'll do a show on that day because
that's kind of similar but um yeah so
Scientology probably based on black
magic even though they don't want to say
any black magic is really more just
about orgies and taking drugs pretty
much yeah although the weird thing about
that is that Scientology was almost kind
of like the other direction of hiring
uptight which which I didn't know when I
didn't know at first about Scientology
yeah they're very anti - give it to an
arc or
Christian entire corporate Christianity
type veneer over it but it was it was a
machine designed to suck money out of
your pocket yes that's what which is
kind of strange given the origins of it
cuz motor cult which Scientology is and
which a lot of the black magic societies
were I mean really pretty much their
whole reason for existing was sex magic
rituals and different drugs and stuff
like that like he said giving it a
higher purpose like you were doing
something important well that was a good
line to get to babe yeah you could get
babes involved in this if there was some
the spirit mysterious magical [ __ ] you
excessive [ __ ] use and you know a lot of
theatricality to it of course well yeah
I'm not able to get our beam of the day
yeah it's not exactly what it was yeah
and you know since we kind of mentioned
that to you I wanted to go back and talk
a little bit about you know like I said
how curly wasn't you know he was a
sexual libertine like I said which was
kind of going on at the time he was
really in a Percy Shelley and that kind
of stuff and he actually published a
book of poetry called white stain yeah
yeah and he actually couldn't publish it
in England because it was illegal there
I mean all drug yeah was homosexuality
was illegal there Oscar Wilde has gone
to prison in 1895 only a couple years
before white stains was published so you
know they did kind of take it seriously
and yeah so he promises I've actually
read was its online if anybody wants to
look it up just look up Aleister Crowley
white chains the whole all of the songs
are now some of them are not you know
some of them are just like poems is that
it's probably not shocking by any by
today's standards obviously from the
eighteen hundreds but I can see how late
eighteen hundreds early nineteen
hundred's that would be very shocking
because there was [ __ ] about like you
know bestiality and necrophilia and like
smelling poop and that's why how some of
that stuff got into black metal music of
the 80 probably with them and probably
venom was all into that they mentioned
bestiality yeah I mean you know stuff
like it my hands with all Putridity is
to choose I Danny
chuckles Mexico you know I like it yeah
to probe thy belly and to drink the
godless fluids and the pool of right
putrescence from the stool and you know
that's not like venom lyrics yeah that's
what I mean that's probably where they
from but yeh so you know about having
sex with animals and poses and eating
[ __ ] and stuff with that so you can see
why that was a little alarming Carly
playing his games it was actually
everybody did when he wrote that - I
think he was in his early twenties
running late yeah but that was pretty
much I mean he got into English
literature when he was in college
nobody knows yeah but then actually they
couldn't publish it in England and I
think even copies that got into England
they mostly got burned they published it
in Amsterdam and it was the same
publisher that published Oscar Wilde
stuff and run Aubrey Beardsley and yes
Curley evidently admired Oscar Wilde but
he didn't want to end up like that well
yeah you know no one wants to end up
like I feel Donald's right poor guy
trying to keep his Jay action on the
down low yeah yeah but it's still kind
of leaked out yeah because he was in his
house was actually under surveillance by
the police yeah I called him because of
all the homosexual a black man is just
worried about it you know he no I like
the booty but I'm straight I'm all van
I'm all man that's what he said except
here was the bottom according about
according to that gasps yeah what's his
name I can't rub it out a bit yeah yeah
but yeah he was a bottom so uh although
I should say that when he first
published wise things he published it
under a pseudonym it's actually under
George Archibald Bishop was the
pseudonym he he published it in her
because you don't want it in trouble I
said but uh okay so what the next story
well we're coming up on the halfway
point are right halfway already I know
God we're blathering I might have to be
just a little bit longer show this is
such a huge topic I now well like I said
well we can do a part two at some point
if we don't agree is it cook we don't
get to everything but so I'm going to
stop right here and take a break so we
will be back in just a few minutes with
more fun Aleister Crowley's doing it's
like Aleister Crowley rambling yeah
rambling about all of our shows over but
yeah he's funny though yeah he's a fast
efficient can forgive us for
kind of DXL if I would I would have
liked to hang out even though most of
the like most egregious stuff about him
like baby sacrifices of like that I'm
sure it's not really no it's not true
but but he probably did you know bring
women home to his wife and then you know
he'd hang the wife up in the closet by
her heels where he was screwing his new
girlfriend that's pretty weird she
didn't go crazy she did yeah yeah yeah
she did say that but yeah you know so he
got a dick move yeah kind of I think you
guys had addicts maybe some girls into
it but I don't think she was into it no
she didn't seem like you know according
why she finally right yeah she's really
okay okay so we're going to take a break
and we'll be back in just a few minutes
how do people who make stuff up for a
living make stuff up we are trying to
special her Jonathan Mayberry told us
all we wronged them Oprah's Book Club
favorites sue Miller como do you sort of
take a jerk during make some bad things
happen hope we have time to do that we
colored them just like a cocktail party
except to your head so join us every
Thursday for the buyers club odd casts
slightly unhinged podcast where
storytellers interview other storyteller
available on project entertainment
networks iTunes and everywhere podcasts
are heard
once upon a time a madman pilot in thief
known as John Rick that's me
challenged himself myself to write a
story
every day for a year by hand some of
them worked
some of them fed some of them were
spectacular
then I did together join me every week
for ink stains as I do a third time and
I will read you some of these stories
I'll talk about the process about
creativity in general writing in
specific and maybe I can help many more
artistic adventures subculture courses
in clothing is our favorite store for
unusual clothing shoes and accessories
they offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 three sides with
years the usual gang of idiots that need
for gold a New York Times bestselling
authors my name is Jim more interviews
with pop culture stars and creators of
some challenging neighboring and they
don't talk about politics course one of
them was a classic point the human today
I said they don't talk about politics
I suspect we may then narrow rule that
no politics will be rich and to talk
about politics of the beer didn't you
say they don't talk about politics if
somebody else says something we should
thank you anyone hear me about all alone
here three guys with beards Tuesdays
exclusively on project Entertainment
Network
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay more fun Carly story yeah now first
okay now here is a story this is just
very brief but you know most people have
heard of their Hermetic order of the
Golden Dawn and stuff like that and
Carly got into that now he was kind of
mad at first because when he first
entered I guess they put you into outer
orders and it takes like a really long
time yeah this is a good story to like
work your way like up to the levels and
everything like that he was like [ __ ]
that yeah he's like [ __ ] down I need to
be the boss of this [ __ ] right now
so he actually went through most of the
levels and he paid the money and all
that other stuff went through his ot
well he was there deep level and
everything and but then he really wanted
to get into the second order that was
like the real you know that was like you
know the outer road was kinda like the
kids table
so he wanted to get into the big [ __ ]
where like you know WB Yeats and all the
big big guys were yeah
so evidently to do that because you know
it's funny cuz the gold dog was
recruiting celebrities just like science
in Scientology which is probably 100
celebrities work yeah yeah
so so as evidently to get into the
second order you actually needed a
recommendation and you had to be in for
seven months yeah I'd be in for seven
months you need a recommendation from
the leader whose name was what was his
name
laser yeah I think it's something like
that please correct me if I'm wrong and
I was like I have a million things not
really important yeah but so actually
those two kind of colluded at first
because Maher said okay you could you
can be in hair on giving a
recommendation now all the other members
didn't like that because they didn't
like curly they thought he was a jerk
and they thought he was trying to take
over the [ __ ] yeah and the leader
actually thought he wouldn't be able to
the temptation of evil you know that was
a different guy though that was Alan
Bennett oh oh yeah that's right all
right no they were friends though they
were France s but yeah so what ended up
happening was there was like a rift in
the Golden Dawn and there was like a
mutiny right now what end up having was
Mather and curly they said we're going
to take over the ship real walk everyone
else out he's going to break in and
repaint stuff yeah and then it was like
a big thing the cops came all his other
stuff and then curly got kicked out and
then I think the Golden Dawn kind of
dispersed after that you know you forgot
to tell him about how he learned all his
knowledge he actually learned it behind
him Alan Bennett yeah there was another
but who was a high up member and they he
befriended him Bennett was hurting for
money because he was on heroin yeah so
cruelly paid his drug bills and then let
him live in a department with it because
the guy was just about destitute and
that's how he learned all his yeah so he
learned all the shader from Alan Bennett
and those two were friends for a long
time like he went after Alan Bennett
went to a monastery and of ceylon in a
way she stole his occult knowledge kind
of yet like you do yeah like I said he
could ye cheat you got a cheat sheet so
yeah so anyway there was a big rift and
all this other kind of [ __ ] now
evidently there was some there was like
a fallout between like later on between
Crowley and between Mather the head who
had been the head of it and accessible
because so these two engaged evidently
in a kind of magical [ __ ] fight yeah
yes yeah where Crowley came to get he
came I think it was in Paris right yeah
I should get some [ __ ] but better still
had a magical [ __ ] and he said that
Mather
I hope I'm getting it there right had
sent a female vampire one of the best
characters will send a female vampire
yeah she wanted to suck out his solo or
what over the woman kinda because
apparently he said he met with this
woman like they went to tea yeah and it
was an old it was an old hag woman right
yeah and so he's like having tea and the
woman's like [ __ ] and milk or something
laughter
the cream and he looks up and she's just
hot as hell and a yawn and she kept
getting more and more beautiful yeah
coming had in Kherson Inman and Ben's
yet and she was trying to put it put her
mouth on his mouth yeah I like suck out
his essence or whatever got into yeah he
fought her on and then he fought her off
yeah and then and then when she reverted
back to him and he reverted back to an
old hag again and that somehow that
defeated the vampire I don't remember
exactly what she didn't disintegrate or
anything no I hope if you said he's not
man she just went back into a woman
should be yeah and I get it really
scares like okay you win so then Crawley
ran around bragging that he defeated a
vampire that's a good fit but okay like
there are purrs because live a guy is
little more 4ps yes my rational question
I'm pretty stupid to see it is like at a
tans up for this old woman's on the end
what if it happened I we only have
Crowley's words here oh yeah and you
know heroic it was a bit of a fantasy
yeah he was he was the show like l ron
hubbard was face made up all kind of
funny really
now we read a lot about this yeah it was
going on but yeah we did this magical
rights and that magical right and then
we did this and that and it never really
said what happened or if they got the
power
you know like for instance they never
really say this magic did anything they
always just say oh it was a success it
was a success well how is it a success
what happened well it's magic man you
can't add enough you know they're very
vague you know I guess you could just
say it was like prayer we prayed on it
and it went it worked and it works
yes that's essential that's not
necessarily magicians throwing lightning
bolts or using the force or throwing
fireballs or anything out of Dungeons
and Dragons is more about which only a
sinking epic if they had done that
getting high
doing a having orgies and then doing
obscene sex acts that you normally
wouldn't do yeah you know just get
yourself an excuse put in a fancy veneer
on a crown right yeah another excuse to
have sex
like anyone D is one I'm just getting
organic but a good dog hater so what I
don't stop anyway not explaining that so
let's go with something a little bit
more off the wall yeah cuz we get more
off the wall well no I mean also well in
the sense that kind of veering off in a
direction now what maybe a lot of people
that aren't super familiar with curly
don't know is that other than being an
occultist and black magician or whatever
he was also quite an accomplished
Mountaineer yes and he actually kind of
got into that in college and he was in
the you know the Scottish mountain
climbing society or whatever and he was
actually on the first expedition to
tackle k2 yeah which at this this was a
you know early twenty nineteen hundred
that hadn't been done yet it was hot but
they don't go record yeah they got to
20,000 feet which no one had done I got
when he was on that expedition so you
know he was no slouch yeah but he had a
friend named Oscar Ekans fan who was
kind of a you know big deal in the
mountaineering world and he would he did
many X's to the Alps and stuff like that
now in 1905 evidently Curley got a
little big for his britches and he got
in on this expedition to climb and I
hope I'm pronouncing this right kangjun
junga and himalayas okay and at the time
in the mountain probably still now in
mountaineering lore it was kind of
considered the world's most treacherous
mountain okay and Curley did not pay for
the expedition that was that was a
different guy Swift guy whose name I
can't browse but um you know that the
Swiss guy was like you know he wanted
him to come with him now the problem
with curly evidently and people that
knew him said this too is that he was
not content to just be one of the gang
he wanted to be in charge of [ __ ] yeah
what magical reasons yeah what ended up
happening and this is kind of a sad
story but on this particular expedition
19:05 they went to this mountain and he
predictably curly predictably tries to
kind of take over the [ __ ] yeah but you
know what you got you got to tell them
what the expedition looked like it was
like what the expedition that you see in
the movie King Kong where they took a
lot of people with ya you wanna see
white guys and then a whole bunch of
Nile white guys carry in all the boxes
they had quarters what was 200 plotters
and like that they were trying to get
away from it all they were trying to
bring it all with me that trust about
contrived evidence it was doomed from
the very beginning it would have been
totally ridiculous to try to get up that
mountain with that many people and that
much stuff yeah they probably want to
set camp and have parties when they got
to the top and you know yeah why would
you need all that yeah well we yelled it
but they're falling off the mountain I
think they lost three or four Porter
yeah what enough happening was there was
there was argument like pretty much from
the very beginning
well no because they thought that Curley
was being too reckless like he didn't
really know exactly what he was doing I
didn't cuz like I said this is a very
dangerous mountain now what ended up
happening and y'all think I realize this
dude gets high like crazy he's probably
taking drugs probably yeah well I mean
at the time they were mostly legal yeah
they probably average but if you imagine
if you could you imagine trying to run
and test a whole mountain climbing party
at 200 people of a treacherous Mountain
where you're just whiter up off a smokin
hot she is
yeah it was probably pretty entertaining
yeah you know to watch from far away I
do but yeah what end up happening so
there was like a big mutiny
and most of the other Mountaineers were
like [ __ ] this too dangerous we're going
back yeah and Crowley said that he told
them don't go back it's too dangerous
yeah this is what Carly said and evident
it's done if he did say that he was
correct because when they were trying to
go back they lost three Porter's and
they also lost one of the main
Mountaineers whose name was Alexis hash
or Pasha
yeah all this curly pulled pistol all
over
threaten to kill him - yeah that's right
you know but the details are vague yeah
now later
like I said curly essentially you know
these four guys it was an avalanche
before guys got killed and curly
evidently he stayed in his tent the
whole time even though there was people
like yelling for help and like some of
the other expeditioners like went to
help the guys and curlies like [ __ ] you
guys and say in my pen I told you not to
go right yeah and evidently the next day
after the Avalanche and after the people
been killed and everything like that he
went down the mountain and he didn't
even like possum my banded this part he
just like passed by I was like well [ __ ]
all y'all I told you not to go anywhere
another dead so Tibet abandoned his own
horse yeah yeah so kind of a dick move
again yeah I wouldn't say wouldn't say
Crowley was too brave actually yeah
and some sources say also that curly
stole a bunch of the expedition money
Owen did he had not put up I wouldn't
doubt although the guy that put the
exhibition together he did get some of
it back later by essentially
blackmailing Curley and saying I'm going
to tell them that you're the one that
wrote that dirty book and everything at
the prison so give me some of the money
back bro
so evidently that happened but yeah so
that was kind of a disastrous expedition
and nacho didn't really look make curly
look all that good but tell them the
reason why he said he came off that
mountain in a band of the party every
reason why well then the other guy
didn't uh didn't the Oscar guy said that
he because he was scared he got up there
and he started hearing those voices a
demon oh that's right from the mountains
that he got scared he really in he had
to come on down yeah okay he was here in
demon maybe I think he was smoking too
much hashish yeah probably he was
probably have enough mana to bring up in
the tent and stuff like that yeah
probably having all kind of crazy yeah
it wasn't an effect yeah but anyway like
like I said he essentially abandoned the
party and like well [ __ ] you guys do the
Hilton oh yeah do that
and he did it anyway signals yeah it was
a sailor stick
now let's see-oh another another very
popular kind of rumor fact not sure was
that curly was a double agent oh yeah so
that's god yeah yeah evidently rounded
on World War one or World War two yeah
well beause I suppose it was beautiful
but um well the thing about Curly's
political views they were kind of all
over the place and he actually he wrote
for like a lot of kind of you know in
during World War one he wrote for like
probe German propaganda he wrote during
propaganda in the US and stuff like that
and he was also for Irish independence
and he was against that whole you know
against the British and everything I
guess in English rather and so there
came there was a like a lot of
speculation about you know what where
his loyalties lie and stuff like that
yeah it's also kind of funny how he
ended up in the u.s. he was started to
lose all his money and lose his little
yeah girlfriend yeah I ran to the United
States because he was not before like I
said he had a lot of money in the
beginning father's estate he got a lot
of money when he fathered what three or
four inheritances in his life he did
yeah he got long yeah he got several
inheritances over his life and he was
running low on cash and ran to the u.s.
to try his fortunes there brought one of
his girlfriends with him and then
somehow or another they ended up working
for a German I think it was in a German
diplomat of some sort and right in Pro
German propaganda yeah and but later on
he backed off of it saying no I was
actually working for the British and the
Americans I was the one that got
Americans into the war yeah yeah yeah so
he just put a different spin on what yet
he was just writing for cash yeah yes
yeah it seems like he was more like he
didn't really have any political
principles no I think he just kind of
like to talk whatever his penalizes his
political principle was get laid make
money yes that's what it is so they get
laid make money oh yeah
later on you could say he claimed that
he was a double
and he was working for British
intelligence and that the reason he was
writing pro-german stuff and you know
all these propaganda papers in New York
and stuff like that like the fatherland
and all that the reason he was doing
that was to was to make the Germans look
ridiculous yeah that's so is he in to
infuriate the United States into joining
the war right yeah so yeah he said that
that's what he was doing and he also
claimed it has it has been claimed by a
few other historians also that he
actually encouraged the German Navy to
destroy the Lusitania yeah and yes it
created so all this other kind of stuff
yes
and like I you know I don't know how
true any of the stuff is there is some
evidence that he was like kind of asked
about a you know double agent or
intelligence type stuff once there's
something to do with them with them with
Hess in World War two yeah evidently Ian
Fleming wanted who wrote the James Bond
novels I wanted to get Aleister Crowley
in contact with Hess to talk hat into
defecting or something along that line
now it didn't happen though yeah the
British government said no we don't want
to get involved with Crowley's yeah
Crowley was old by then and I think he
died two years after 1947 he died yeah
but that was just one of the in
Fleming's ideas yeah I get to get
Crowley involved okay because heck was
like with in the early 80s was in the
Crowley was in this into the occult and
Hess was also kind of mentally unstable
and Goble yeah yeah okay but uh so you
know like I said there was like a book
that recently solana how recently it was
but that came out that said that they
had proof that he was a double agent
that he was worth of a British knowledge
and stuff like that but I'm not sure how
yeah we have really solid yeah I'm not
sure how solid all of that is but that
is something that goes around about him
a lot that he was
intelligence that he was working for
British intelligence um yeah I say what
how securly was not a british patriot he
didn't care about England he cared about
getting high getting laid
yeah no this time abroad Trant traveling
around yeah I mean he seems like someone
who was very self-absorbed yeah you know
yeah I care about self yeah like it was
like Helen over yeah like I said she
remember very similar I can see why
Harvard would was such a fanboy yeah
but anyway I also wanted to talk a
little bit about his house
Valeska house in Fallon on the shores of
Loch Ness because he bought that house
in 1899 and he wanted to he it was a
specific house because he was doing that
that abra Mellon the mage stuff and in
that book apparently you had to have the
house with you know with a room and it
set aside for the magic and it had to
have a door facing north and then it had
to have you know like a like a saying
like a patio saying outside where he
could like conjure demons and all his
other kind of stuff and so apparently
what he lives there for many years
and he did all kind of like black magic
rituals there and evidently the
townspeople were not too happy about it
and a lot of things were attributed to
him being there like you know it was
said that a lot of people that worked in
a house like workmen and stuff like
their kids died mysteriously and you
know that there was that people would
see like shadow figures like up on this
up on the porch or whatever and I think
even like a butcher in town died and
like good backup blame horribly sick
yeah and I'm sure like I said you know
what was he doing in there having orgies
getting high like usual good you know
and he probably he thought he was
conjuring demons I imagine sure um yeah
he also have to have a little bit this
way um Chloe loves when these stories
would hit the media oh yeah he was super
in him yeah he loves attention and he
loved to be facing charges criminal
charges he didn't hear because if he
ever if when he when his name got in the
papers he got more followers yes because
he was constantly burning his followers
out drinking up all their money and
wearing them out you know just
physically and emotionally because you
know to under he was of what you'd call
a very brutal master if you wanted to
learn from him you were going to pay
money to finance his lifestyle you were
going to do things like sleeping on
hardwood floors and cold uh not much
food and sexual abuse but he actually is
what was going to happen if you wanted
to be his mess if you wanted to learn
from him yeah so you know he might keep
a wealthy student for a few months maybe
a few years and then that student become
disenfranchised or you know disenchanted
with the guy and leave where he had to
get new ones yeah and every time he'd
show up in the paper he'd get some new
ones or he get new girls he had all
these girls that were wanted to be
sorceresses and hang out with magicians
and sorcerers and black men and black
magic guys who he had a mystique to him
you know yeah uh so he was apparently
real charismatic yeah you know so you
know he loved he loved to be in the
newspapers yeah and and you know the
more negative press he got I guess the
more attracted the kind of women he was
into well yeah and honestly the media
kind of played into it by Colin you know
like the wickedest made in the world and
all the other stuff and I'm sure they
made up a bunch of [ __ ] about him and he
just was like yeah I'm rolling with it
okay yeah and all that he had bad girls
coming at him from all over Europe and
he I would say that even though I didn't
run you know I I think the guys are
using personally I wouldn't be a kind of
guy hanging out
what I think I get tired of a guy like
that real quick exactly how I'd have to
say that he was a success he burned
through three or four inheritances lived
out his entire life doing what he wanted
to do get high and have sex with young
good-looking women yeah I think his last
girlfriend was what 17 or 18 probably
ass and he was doing seventies I said
you know because I'm Alistair magical
[ __ ] crap Alistair [ __ ] cross
there was one but yeah how some you know
he eventually I'd end up selling it and
actually I became famous
Valeska health leader because Jimmy Page
from Led Zeppelin bought it specifically
because Aleister Crowley has live
Berenice you know and then summon demons
the one not on story about to Abby which
one which story
Ramona guys the guy to does tell me that
story which guy that died you got to
died there with his student that died
here they buried him oh that's right now
now I think he reported his death yeah
whose word do we have of that just like
his wife's words whatever while Roger
came she didn't want to come right right
we just saw this in a documentary
yesterday so I can't even remember what
her name was Lucy the story she said
that that they came there it was kind of
you know her husband's idea like he
wanted yeah the husband was really what
she wasn't it and she wasn't into it and
yeah he ended up dying yeah they just
gave him some so many drugs yeah and
they gave me such a such a harsh ritual
of magical training that he got sick and
weekends and she was like we got to get
out of here you're gonna die no no I'm
gonna stay here you know don't press any
charges and the guy ended up died anyway
yeah and they just picked him up and
took him buried in yeah on the property
operty yeah and this was it was just
wasn't a burlesque in houses was this
was much later but yeah what in what is
rain wasn't it yeah there's one like
that well just banner Italy generator
lead and can you remember we just
stopped like I said this is that was
that wasn't one of the one that was
different that was that was the first
time I've heard that story
yeah it was kind of amazing he didn't
come up on murder charges but then it
was different time those 40 so and I got
this nobody reported it we reported it
it would
that I get 100 murder nowadays it
probably considered negligent homicide
yeah well because going back to
Scientology that yeah that's what
happened was Lisa McPherson right they
blatantly just like locked her in a room
and she died right none of them were
convicted and I'll tanks but that was
negligent I didn't get this person help
no yeah but so we only have a few
minutes left so I did kind of want to
mention this one because this one went
around the internet a lot that Aleister
Crowley was the grandfather of George
Bush yes and you know what is sounds
crazy it suffices but this is plausible
it could be it was known you would have
been the yeah the grandfather of George
Bush yeah yeah the grandfather because
what ended up happening Barbara Bush's
mother was named Pauline Pierce Pauline
Pierce was in Paris in the 1920s and
Crowley was also in Paris and evidently
Pauline Pierce hung out with curly and
kind of parties with the six men with
the sex magic shot doctor so there is
some speculation that Roly could have
knocked up Pauline peers your during one
of the sex rituals which would make
because apparently Pauline had Barbara
Bush eight months after her parents so
run which would have made George Bush
Senior big Bush the GI right right right
that's rude no no Molly Pierce was
Barbara Bush's mother okay Barbara Bush
is nice so that what I made yeah jr.
George Bush jr. little Bush would have
made him too grandpa right no George HW
Bush wanted grandpa George W Bush would
be the great grand the great grandpa
Allen Arabella now like I said there
he's really probably no way of proving
this and I'm sure the Bush family are
like done river with DNA that's true he
had his i'ma curl his DNA good yeah I
wonder if he was going to Crowley's DNA
you think he would have fathered so many
children I'm coming he did it I feel
have died but yeah yeah I think
good live he was knocking knocking those
girls up and then just cutting them
loose yeah not never deceit never be
seen again
yeah I might be related to Ellen after
all not know it it's possible when you
got around you had to put a picture of a
bush side-by-side with the young Crawley
and see if there were any if there's any
sense exactly going to do this but it
was like a very yeah this is actually a
very popular internet meme that went
around there that curl but like I said
is it true I don't know it's plausible
dhalsim this plausible cuz she did kind
of hang out in the survival but unlikely
it's unlikely but yeah it's but it could
happen July cool I do it's a cool mister
crawling dude I totally but when when we
decided to do the show I said I'm going
to put I'm gonna play right right right
before the end credits I'm gonna play a
segment of that current 93 song yeah
yeah I'm really narrowly knots on that
early man cuz I like that song yeah put
that mr. crippling big mr. Crowley in
there oh yeah maybe I will say whoa put
that down we'll have a little musical
interlude it but anyway oh [ __ ] okay so
we're coming up to the end of the show I
can't no I can't believe we yeah we have
to come back on Crawley we will do
another show yeah we didn't like even
cover what does it look I don't cover
one topic about him yeah we just wanted
to do kind of general our favorite story
here I have so much information on the
guy yeah so what okay so what do I
usually do at the end okay so I usually
say a few projects Entertainment Network
and I'm going to put a link to their
patreon on the YouTube video to go there
patreon game above so I have a cool
chrony shirt I would like to do a curly
shirt at someone oh we got actual
samples of our shirts and the quality is
very good that's right I forgot to say
we got we got a Burl's of a t-shirt and
I got one of the ones with like the
fancier logo on it yeah and actually I'm
very happy with that again yeah very
nice one thing I must say though if
you're one of these guys that sometimes
wears a medium and sometimes wears a
large t-shirt go for the medium they
actually a little bit too big I think
the largest like a large is a little big
yeah right so I think they run a little
bigger size yeah
just keep them but if yeah if you guys
are thinking of buying our shirts you
know like I said that'll calm plus 13
o'clock
eventually I'll put a curly shirt up I'm
not going to make any promises about
what it's going to be because I don't no
one has time to do it but a young curly
on there well yeah I'm not coming I'm
not putting the old bonk early on
they're all fat that's probably in his
diaper oh I've already had that yeah
kind of dressed up like almost like
Gandhi yeah divert it's sad because like
actually probably when he was when he
was a young man was actually pretty
good-looking he was a pretty good
good-looking dude you know he had money
yes news young he seems like you said
though I don't know if I would I want to
hang out with him he well he was og man
he was original guy he was real tough
you thing like you've been annoying [ __ ]
though oh yeah after a while he just
like y'all are age yes and I can't stand
lr incident with a [ __ ] mouth I'm not
anyone really arrogant egotistical
know-it-all yeah yeah I don't like that
so anyway so yeah that's the end of the
show I'm going to put a couple little
musical interludes at the end to
entertain y'all and get out you know
yeah on the way out what it's like in my
Scion and anyway so if you liked the
show
be sure to subscribe to our channel here
on YouTube or you know go listen to us
on project Entertainment Network listen
to their other podcast you because
they're really good and also like us on
Facebook and follow us on Twitter we're
at 13 o'clock podcast and I think that's
probably going to do it for the show
right
that's for Brenner nuts yeah okay that
was for you I hope you enjoyed that
collab Lincoln is shall we not go show
yeah we did good we did go fish so we'll
see you guys next Tuesday
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]